um second
round uh until 12 um
so uh
we ended off on talking about i'll
actually go back to the
uh slide where i was discussing the
setting that we're in just to
maybe catch anybody who missed like the
first bit up to date
so we're talking about experimental
design for causal structure learning
we're starting off by talking about
non-adaptive settings where we pick all
of the interventions that we're going to
do at a single point in time
um we're talking about
um previously we talked about bounded
size interventions so uh
interventions where we only have a
single intervention target now we're
going to talk about uh interventions of
unbounded size so this is where
the intervention can have multiple
targets it can
uh you know potentially either
do a do intervention on multiple uh
variables all at once where it can
change the mechanisms of a bunch of
variables all at once
so you can think about something
like uh
in in the genomics example knocking out
two genes instead of just knocking out
one gene uh in the system that you're
taking data from
um
we're
in a setting where we have no
observational data going in so it's kind
of the the worst case we have to
deal with any possible graph um whereas
in the setting with observational data
going in we could be dealing with any
graph just in a mark of certain markov
equivalence class
and finally
we're going to be
still in this
setting where we're
trying to fully identify the graph at
the minimum cost
so
the question
was you know
taking all those things into account um
how many interventions are sufficient
and in the worst case necessary for
finding any graph g star
on uh some number of nodes p
um
and
the answer to this question was uh
that
we get this
floor of log base two of p plus an extra
intervention
and we walked through the
proof of this being sufficient
um
now we'll go through
the proof of this also being necessary
in the worst case and this is going to
be like an induction style argument so
we'll assume that the result holds for
all numbers less than what we're trying
to prove it for um
you can do the base cases for two three
and four
uh pretty easily by hand
to get you started so if you do
you know say for instance
uh two nodes
what is
this bound in that case
uh so the claim is that uh in the worst
case we need
two interventions of unbounded
size um so
uh
we basically have to convince ourselves
that we wouldn't be able to identify
this in only a single intervention
um
and this goes back to
uh the argument uh from earlier and kind
of the mistake that it had on the single
node intervention case where we have to
quantify for p greater than three
uh because if we only intervene
on a single node
uh
then we say uh
do a do intervention um so we're setting
this node to a specific value
then we won't be able to tell between
the case where these two variables are
independent
in the case where these two
variables are
dependent in the observational setting
but we've removed that dependence
because of our intervention
is that clear why this holds
when p equals two
and then we would get you know
it would still be two interventions for
three nodes and
uh three interventions and for four
nodes
um so i won't walk through those
um
but
that will get us started and then we do
an induction argument where
uh now we have p nodes
and
we say okay our first intervention
uh well these are unbounded so it can be
on any number of nodes
uh k in the graph
um
and
what's kind of the worst case that we
can imagine so we pick these k nodes
without knowing anything about the graph
and then
um
the
nodes that we don't intervene on
if these are all upstream of the
nodes that we do intervene on
uh we don't get any information about
them
um
furthermore other than that they're
upstream but we don't get information
between these nodes
and then in the worst case this could be
a complete graph over those nodes
um and then
when we were talking about the
kind of adjacency and orientation tests
we mentioned that if we do an
intervention that includes two variables
we get no information
about them so if i do an intervention
that includes
both of these variables
then
i can't conclude whether or not there's
an edge between them or whether there's
uh or the direction so i mean i don't
even know if there's an edge of course i
can't determine a direction
so in general i basically have just
in the worst case partitioned my graph
into
a
complete graph over
uh the p minus k nodes and a complete
graph over the k notes
and
then uh
now you know that's less than both of
those are less than p
so
by our induction hypothesis
uh one of those remaining graphs
uh so
one of them has to be
of size
p over two or larger
um
just because i can at best split it in
half so one of those graphs will require
that should be
a
floor here um i think
both of those should be floor
um
and then because of this
uh division by two i guess basically log
base two of p minus one and then i add
the one back so that's how many
interventions are required to enter like
do the remaining part plus the one
intervention that i already used so
that's what's giving me
uh
satisfying the induction hypothesis at
greater values
cool so
now we're going to start moving on to uh
from here on out we'll be in settings
with observational data
any questions before i move to that
about these settings without
observational data
actually sorry it's going forward so
yeah observation that i asked earlier
sorry your
essential graph that's what you pulled
right
and then what i was going to ask here is
uh
in the case of an enormous gene network
there might not be
say there's
no observations at all on
the subset of this 20 000 genes
yeah so this is essentially the question
was uh in something like a gene
regulatory network where uh it's like
human cells we have about 20 000 genes
what if not all those genes get measured
so this goes back to kind of the problem
of latent confounding because you've
marginalized out some of the variables
in the distribution that you're looking
at
um so
that's going to be kind of this costly
and sufficient setting that i won't
touch until kind of the very end
okay
yeah yeah so i'll discuss some works in
like the very end
um that everything's right now i'm going
to be in this nice setting
awesome um so i'll move on so now you
can see the only thing that changed from
the previous setting that we're in is
that now we're going to assume that we
have
observational data
and
this is going to require some some new
terminology to get up to speed on kind
of what the algorithm that i'm going to
introduce actually does
and i'm going to give kind of the punch
line first and then kind of explain the
terms
but there's this nice characterization
of
the interventional essential graphs uh
as satisfying these two properties one
is that it's a chain graph
will impact what that means
and then so chain graph has chain
components and we're going to say each
of those is chordal
and then
another useful result kind of in this
field is that within each of these chain
components
the orientations are
of different edges are kind of logically
independent of each other if you orient
something in one of the chain components
you can't conclude anything about
orientations in a different chain
component
right so first
um and i have
i haven't been saying with all these
references like i'm trying to put as
many of the references down here
especially for things that i'm not
proofing
um
right so
the chain graph is essentially a
generalization of a directed acyclic
graph
that's going to have both directed and
undirected edges so this is a different
form of mixed graph than we saw in the
workshop on causal structure learning
causal discovery where we were
considering bi-directed edges we had two
types of directed and bi-directed
here
uh just like we are talking about with
essential graphs it's
directed and undirected so that
generally in this talk is going to be
what i mean by a mixed graph it's
directed and undirected
and
we're going to extend the notion of a
cycle from a completely directed graph
so a dag
into a um or just a directed graph into
these mixed graphs so
we're going to call a
sequence of edges a partially directed
cycle if um
basically
it looks like it could be a cycle with
uh undirected edges
but
uh since we have directed edges
uh two things have to happen
one is that there's
at least one directed edge
in this thing and also
all the directed edges are kind of in
the same direction so if i start going
this way
it's not like i have a directed edge
that way that would not be a partially
directed cycle if i have another
directed edge it has to be
in the same way
right so those are the
the two conditions and i'm just being
lazy and saying
that like we'll call v minus one this vn
so that we can make sure that it's a
cycle
um and similar to our definition of a
dag as a directed graph with no
directed cycles this will a chain graph
is going to be a mixed graph with no
partially directed cycles
um
and for instance this guy up here is
going to be a chain graph um
yes if if we tried to look for any
partially directed cycle in here we
couldn't there's not
maybe there are equivalent
characterizations where this is a little
easier to see
um but the main point here is that i
wanted to give you the definition of
chain components as well
so
uh if we kind of remove all the directed
edges from this mixed graph and then we
just take um
we take the connected components of the
kind of remaining only undirected graph
so kind of transitivity under the
relation of being connected by
undirected edges these will give us the
chain components so we see this
one of four nodes up here the single
node component and it's two nodes
um
so that was kind of the first definition
that's involved in that result the
second definition
uh is what it's a chordal graph so the
claim is that each of those chain
components
um in this
uh interventional essential graph is
also chordal
um
and
uh to define this we need to say what a
chord is um which
if we take a cycle of length greater
than four this is just going to be
an edge that connects two things in the
cycle that are
uh
where the edge itself is not in the
cycle
right so
um basically something that cuts through
and makes this no longer necessarily
like a cycle of length four
i guess it's still a cycle of length
four but there's kind of a short cut
through it
um and a chordal graph is going to just
be an undirected graph where
every uh cycle greater than four has a
chord um and these have really nice kind
of
graph theoretic computational properties
um that get used a lot kind of in this
field of
experimental design
one of the properties that it has
is that it's
easy to find the largest clique in this
graph so clique is
instead of nodes which are all adjacent
so if we just look at the induced
subgraph
it's a complete graph
and the clique number of some undirected
graph is the size of the largest clique
and i'll be using this throughout this
omega g
yeah
so basically yeah so you basically cut
it down to link three cycles okay
and then like yeah for anybody who's
worried about oh are we gonna be using
the the click number like
computationally in any way um are we
going to be trying to find that extra
large tanks and stuff that's usually an
npr problem in the case of chordal
graphs uh this can be computed
efficiently i think in linear time
um another thing that can be computed
efficiently that we'll be using for
chordal graphs
is this idea of a coloring which is just
an assignment of colors
to the graph
such that two adjacent nodes are not
the same color so for instance
this is a coloring of the graph on the
right with four colors
and similar to the quantity that we had
for
the
size of the largest clique we can ask
for the size of the smallest coloring
and that's going to be called the
chromatic number of the graph i don't
really use that term it is very
convenient for chordal graphs
the
the chromatic number is actually equal
to the clique numbers the clique kind of
tells you how many colors you have to
use
and you can be clever and
reuse those colors that you used on the
largest cleat kind of throughout the
graph
um and again yeah
this will actually be used
computationally
um in this next algorithm is uh being
able to find an optimal coloring of a
graph so coloring of the smallest number
of colors um and that can also be done
efficiently for choral graphs
okay
so
now we get back to our
question that motivated all this kind of
technical material which is how many um
the
unrestricted sized interventions are
going to be sufficient and in the worst
case necessary
for determining some
uh
the true graph out of some
uh
markov equivalence class
um and the answer
now instead of depending on the number
of nodes is going to depend on the
clique number of the essential graph and
here i'm being a little
sloppy with notation so typically we use
the clique number to
it's a function of
undirected graphs the essential graph
can be a mixed graph
but because we have these chordal chain
components what we can do is just look
at each one of those individually and
take this clip number to be the size of
the largest clique in any of those
so that's just a note on kind of my
sloppy notation here
and i also don't know
if i kind of harped on um
the notation that i'm using for the
essential
graph so previously i was saying
um with the subscript of the
interventions that's the i essential
graph similarly to the
markov equivalence class i'll just
remove the subscript when i'm talking
about the observational setting
so this is just your plain old kind of
essential graph no
interventions involved in its definition
um
and
luckily the strategy
looks a lot like the strategy that we
just saw
so
instead of assigning each vertex a
distinct
number
we're going to first find an optimal
coloring
um
and then assign the colors a number
and then we're going to use kind of the
same construction
for the intervention set so the example
would be probably more clear than the
text
um so that was the graph that we had
earlier that's an optimal coloring of
the graph
um
we can just think of these coloring
these colors is corresponding to numbers
and i'm writing out their binary
representations here
so i have four colors so now i should be
able to do it in
two interventions
um and the way that i do that so i look
at what my definition is the first
intervention
has to have
the
uh
the targets be everything
whose color has a one
in the right hand position
so that's the the purple and the blue
and then the second one is going to be
the orange and the blue and by the fact
that this is the coloring this is going
to guarantee that any two adjacent nodes
will have at least one intervention that
targets one but not the other
yeah
yeah so these results are for the first
place and i was wondering if there is
some literature that connects graphical
features
into a number of interventions
appear expected to
perform yeah yeah um
so the question was all these results
are in the worst case are they're
basically results that kind of more
graph specific that use the graphical
features to
tell you about how many interventions
you might need to perform
um
so the answer is yes some of that's
going to be in
the the end of the top
i think that's kind of
more preliminary so it's not super well
developed
but there are some kind of graph
specific balance that you can get
on the number of interventions that are
necessary
even kind of markup
uh
equivalence class specific balance
for that as well
one more question
i know you said that we are going to
look at the case where possible
sufficiency doesn't fall
just quickly comment
but we have
called the position in a second
it's very intervening
then i feel like it shouldn't be that
much of a problem but yes
there are ways to do it with uh
interventions that are
undoubted in science but there's
encountering examples to when you only
have
um single node interventions you can't
even hope to actually pinpoint the graph
um
so it depends a little bit more on
what the kind of experimental
limitations that you're dealing with are
um and i think that's also i mean
there's like
the two results of unbounded and like
single node but then
there's probably open questions on what
comes in between notes
um
okay
so i just wanted to
pull out a few um
a few papers that i'm not going to be
going over here uh but just kind of
links to these results if people are
interested so when i was
talking about the bounded case i was
really just focusing on bounded bible
and i wasn't giving general results for
when the size of the interventions are
bounded by some other numbers so say
maybe in genomics experiments you're
doing knockouts and so actually i can do
two or three at a time
and i want to see you know how much
better can i do if i'm allowed to do
that instead of just one
uh
thing knocked out per intervention
so
um
that case is covered
in
uh this paper and um i had a interesting
question during the break it was
basically you know like we have this
kind of logarithmic dependence on the
number
of um
the clique size in this case or like in
the case of no observational data the
number of nodes
um we had this logarithmic dependence
when it was unbounded and we had this
linear dependence it was bounded like
kind of smoothly interpolate between
that
and this is
essentially going to provide like a
positive answer to that um
not
at risk of you know confusing people and
speaking out of stuff i don't know too
much about um this uh uses this
construction of separating systems on
graphs people know what those are
um and
it kind of uses results from kind of
classical graph theory literature
um to prove stuff about this kind of
interpolating case um and you will see
like the linear term as you add more
interventions
kind of gets divided by the number of
interventions and then the long term
uh kind of
starts creeping
so it does kind of interfere between
needs
and then i've also um
as i mentioned maybe at the beginning of
the
first section
um focused on really minimizing the
number of interventions that are done
kind of assuming all interventions cost
me an equal enough to do
so and
you can imagine this is not always going
to be the case maybe some things are
harder to intervene on maybe i can't
even remain on something so there's kind
of an infinite cost where i can't
include that in my identification
strategy
and there's a paper that
essentially extends this one but allows
for costs on the networks as well
uh
yeah so these these are interesting
things to check out if you know that
sort of stuff and now i'm going to move
on from this kind of minimal cost
identification um
setting
to a setting where you have a fixed
budget and show you some of the things
that can be great about that setting
um
just as an idea
i'm wondering is there in the literature
anyone that has tried to
explore something like
i don't know if can be even modeled in
the causality strategic observation
but
[Music]
we cannot observe everything but
we have to incentivize people in order
to give us the observation and how that
interferes with the society
i'm trying to match that to work
yeah yeah
there's something that
does
in some active sense pick the
interventions very sorry the variables
you're going to be observing
um but i'm not sure how related it is to
this
literature so
um
i i would look up like picking observed
variables or active learning of like
observations or like something like that
literature but that's the only thing i
know
also yeah
obviously the room is full of experts on
this stuff so if anybody wants the china
and other stuff that they know about but
they didn't do that
um
okay so now
uh
i'm going to be i guess
moving to the setting with
um
a fixed budget
so
now instead of saying
these kind of questions of like oh how
many things are
um and in the worst case necessary i'll
say just given a certain amount of
interventions how much can i learn and
my task is going to be to maximize
um in this case uh so it's going to be
the first place where we're using
uh expectations instead of kind of this
worst-case
analysis
and
just for simplicity
and this is actually i think what's done
in the paper um we're going to be using
uh a uniform distribution over the mark
of this class so you can think of this
as
if my level of identifiability only
gives me the markov equivalence class
uh there kind of should be no difference
between two things in the equivalence
class otherwise you know somehow my
prior
whatever i'm using to get this different
distribution over the markup equivalence
class is baking in that some graphs are
preferred over others which may or may
not be your setting but if you're going
to focus purely on what you can identify
from data and no additional assumptions
the uniform prior is natural
um and then
this is like kind of real notation that
this is just going to be counting the
number of directed edges in this i
essential graph so i'm trying to
maximize the number
of directed edges
all right i'll kind of go through
in the adaptive part how there's other
choices that you might
be interested in about how much
information
that you have
but we'll see that
this one suits itself to
the kind of combinatorial optimization
techniques pretty well
and as i said we're going to be doing
single node interventions and we're
going to be choosing km
so uh the
point about it actually being good for
combinatorial optimization is that this
function is we're gonna end up trying
this uh submodulator so
um
to review what submodularity is this
property of set functions so functions
that take in
sets um we'll assume that we have this
like total set or like universe omega
and we can take in any subset and return
a number it's submodular if you have
this kind of
um diminishing returns property so if i
have a set a that's contained in a sub b
then adding
the
element b to a
increases
the
value of the function more than if i
added the value b
to the larger set
um this shows up in a bunch of
settings and it's kind of like a general
way that like you can think of
many information theoretic quantities
working if i
have a certain amount of information a
that's less than uh the amount of
information i have b
like whatever function i'm using to
measure how much information are in
these sets
adding to the
uh
smaller set is going to kind of end up
giving me more information than adding
to the bigger set
um
and we'll see how this comes about with
these directed edges
and then
a second
definition that we need for these types
of functions is
uh that
the step function or some modular
function is going to be monotonically
increasing just if
you know having more things in the set
gives me a bigger value
and
there's kind of a natural way you might
think of optimizing this greedily so if
i'm trying to find the set of size k
that gives me the best value
of this function f
um instead of enumerating over all
subsets of size k
what i can do is just
pick one element at a time so i start
from the empty set
and then i see
what element i can add
that most increases my function given
kind of the current set i have and then
i add that into my set so at each time
i'm just evaluating
however many uh different things are in
the set
and then
um
adding it in so this is a much quicker
thing than kind of enumeration of all
subsets
and kind of classical result
combinatorial optimization is that
if my
step function is both submodular and
monotonically increasing
this greedy optimization strategy will
give me
an approximation guarantee so the thing
that i'll get
is within this factor of the actual
maximum
yeah
so now your items are the possible
interventions yes
because
oh yeah because the single number
yeah yeah so i don't think the proof
here is going to extend to
unbounded size interventions and the the
the theorem is essentially that if i if
i fix a graph
and i take in this intervention set
then
uh if i you know let the function just
measure how many directed edges i have
then this function is monotonically
increasing and similar
but this does rely on this being the set
of single node interventions
so yep
is actually it's not even monotonic
anymore if you have if you intervene in
multiple notes so that makes it really
different
when you actually have a non you can
prove non-monotonic submodularity
and then proves based on that
so one of the things here i think is
that
your objective so the average of
uh monotonous modular functions is
monsoon and sub
you're not gonna know it exactly right
right yeah so the point is um the
objective i'm trying to optimize is this
expected value over
over graphs in the markov equivalence
class
now we haven't discussed too much yet
about the size of the markov equivalence
class but if you imagine like a markov
equivalence class of a complete graph
um i can choose any
uh
any permutation of those various so i
have p factorial so
generally these can be very large um
and
the
one of the reasons i talked i picked
this to talk about is there's actually
nice
uh pretty recent sampling algorithms for
picking
um uniformly at random from a markup
equivalence class in polynomial time
um and that's like within the last is
that like they can do it exactly exactly
exactly an important example oh yeah
yeah
yeah
so if you use this approach you're kind
of already
uh hoping only for approximation
guarantee is
hard to get exactly
um
i mean i think with the maximizing
submodular functions in general it's
known um
that it can be mp hard to get the exact
maximal um with this one i'm not sure if
there's any other structural properties
that would lead to it being
uh
easy to get exactly so i don't think
there's a proof like a empty hardness
reduction or something there
but nobody's proved that it's easy so
that's why we're doing some modulator
all right so
this proof
um
relies on this interesting fact that to
me was at first
counterintuitive that um
if we let
uh if we have two sets of nodes there
are two sets of edges that we get from
separate single node interventions so we
have this e of i1 and e of i2
then
if we take
the
uh so this
right like this could be
i1
is a set of single node interventions so
we could have one intervention on like
say node one one intervention on node
three
so this isn't you know just a single
intervention
the elements are
each
singleton sets
um
then if we take the union of the edges
that we get from both of these
uh
so basically you think of
i
start with a bunch of edges that i
learned from one intervention um and a
bunch of edges i learned from another
intervention now i mix those together
and i ask if i can orient any more edges
uh
the answer is no so
um the
set their union is actually complete
under the the orientation rules
that i think were discussed on
wednesday um they're kind of boring so i
didn't include the orientation rules
again uh we'll talk about
um kind of an example
of how this plays out for a specific one
but it's a kind of tedious proof um so i
just want to give you the flavor of it
but
why would this imply sub modularity they
have kind of the same feeling and then
kind of just walking through the proof
the number of
edges that are oriented if i add
i
um so because of this
the only edges that are additionally
going to get oriented if i add a single
node intervention i to this existing set
of interventions
are exactly the things that are oriented
by i if i hadn't
um
already done those other interventions
first
and then
i'm subtracting out the things that were
already oriented so
uh i also have to do the set difference
there
um so
the
kind of
some modularity condition
reduces to this just checking that
uh these two set differences satisfy
this inequality and that's like a
trivial inequality
yeah yeah so the point is
that i could
have equivalently said
and i think this is actually the way
that it's written
in the paper
that
uh
e
[Music]
i one union i2
equals
can i interpret this theorem that's
another proof for why p minus one
dimensions is enough
um
i had not thought about that i think you
probably can so the question was whether
you can
derive essentially from this theorem uh
the proof that
you need p minus one interventions
is sufficient
uh
yes so it's p minus one single node
interventions we get from each of those
interventions
all of the adjacent seats
to that edge and then we just union over
all of those adjacencies so yeah this is
a good point of sufficiency
um okay so the the kind of sketch of how
this proof works it's the first thing
that we
think about doing is we check
um
the preconditions for invoking any of
the the meat rolls um that involve more
than two edges because how would we get
more edges from
meek rolls
than we had in one of these original
sets so if the if it only involves one
orientation then
whichever set
uh that orientation was in is kind of
sufficient to invoke that meek roll so
it has to be that we
have one of the edges that's invoked in
this that kind of activates the sneak
roll uh coming from one set and the
other edge coming from
the different set
um
but
you can the kind of proof technique is
to show like whenever this happens
the existence of one of the edges in the
first set would imply the other edge is
actually so this should be
i1
is also in the first set so actually it
would turn out that we didn't need the
second set at all
to kind of demonstrate
more specifically
uh
say that we
were to invoke
this make rule that tells us
to avoid cycles so we have
um x1 to x2 and then x2 to x3
we can't make a cycle here so we would
be invoking the
it and direct x1 to x3
um so we check all right so maybe
this edge is from the first set of uh
edges that we learned and this edges
from the second set
okay so let's say it's just this edge
it's in this first step
um well we know this edge can't have
been directly from an intervention
because if
we got it from intervening on x1 then we
would have also gotten this edge and if
we were to get from intervening on x2
we'd have also gotten this edge so
that's ruled out and now we have to
check
uh if it's from any of the other negroes
so there's kind of two layers of micros
that we have to check here which is why
this gets pretty tedious
um
but
for example
one of the meek rolls is
we can't create a new v structure so
perhaps we say perhaps i got this edge
because
actually there's this other variable a
that points into x1
um
but does not
connect to x2
and that's going to give me
um
and if i already had this edge from a to
x1
then
uh
by the fact that i
don't yet have the edge x2 to x1 i have
to orient it this way
okay so so maybe this a is out there and
it's pointing to x1
[Music]
now the claim is that okay there's two
circumstances so i said a is not
connected to x2
but i never said if it's connected to x3
or not it could be either so if it's not
adjacent to x3
then i would get this
uh orientation
the same
uh
the same way so also by invoking this
kind of not creating any new uh b
structures rule
um but if i were if it was actually
adjacent to x3 then there's another meek
roll that gets invoked so you can
essentially see
um if i had this edge and it invoked
this goes this way and that these two
are adjacent
then i can't orient x2 to x3 so i'll do
this on the board
so i'm saying that i have this edge
that gives me this edge
and then
uh
i'm asking can i
orient the edge x2 to x3 well if i did
that i would form this
uh
i can't orient this this way or also i
form a cycle so i know that that's
oriented this way and then because of
this i also get that way but now i've
created a new v structure
uh between a x3 and x2
um so yeah you get this very case-based
analysis
that shows you this this interesting
fact
that uh
just combining the sets of edges that
you get
is going to give you um
you know no new unique rules being
invoked and giving you extra edges and
that is enough to show the submodularity
of this function
um as chris pointed out uh
a
positive linear combination of
submodular functions is still going to
be
uh submodular
so that's what i
have here in in monotonic
and then
the question is how do we efficiently
approximate
this expected value uh so
uh
as kind of suggested we're not going to
actually enumerate everything and then
average it all up we can do this uh kind
of by a monte carlo averaging technique
where we just sample a bunch of things
um until and average them until we get
within you know some comfortable epsilon
and the way to do that is in this recent
paper that
shows you how to
sample from the
markov equivalence class
with this setup time that's
bounded by
essentially the square of the number of
maximal cliques which is also you can
see in chordal graphs that this is going
to be bounded by the number of nodes
so this is essentially kind of at the
worst case
you know some kind of low polynomial in
the number of nodes
and then
that's the setup and then we just sample
from it pretty fast it's kind of linear
time and the number of nodes and edges
so that's all for
the
setup on
kind of passive experimental design
non-adaptive experimental design
strategies
i think it's easier to just go into the
adaptive ones after lunch
so
if anybody has any questions
um i could take those now
yeah so
the question was can we do estimation
and assume you mean of kind of the
say we're in a linear setting estimation
of like the linear regression
coefficients or something
um
and
yeah so generally
interventional data will help us
estimate everything that's not involved
in
kind of the thing that we're actually
intervening on so
if i had this graph like
x1 to x2
to x3
and i intervene on x3 the data
that i get on x1 and x2 from that
intervention is still perfectly good for
kind of estimating this linear
regression coefficient or more generally
the distribution
here
um
so are you asking about something
besides estimating kind of like
given a graph what the parameters are of
the graph
um
yes yes
um so uh
there's kind of two separate things that
we could imagine using experimental
design for like picking our
interventions kind of to maximize when
it's the information that we obtain
about the graph kind of help us identify
what the graph is
the other one is
uh
specifically to learning kind of
parameters of the graph so that we can
make make predictions with it in the
future
um so
i'm not too aware of work which explores
simultaneously wanting to do both of
those there is work that i'll
mention
um in the last section on
uh given a known graph how do i pick
interventions that uh kind of maximize
my uh ability to
infer my parameters
um and that's a little different than
kind of the classical experimental
design setting at least as far as i
understand where you
um
and by classical i mean like not for
causal
structural models but for um you know
kind of oh how do i pick inputs that
allow me to learn say like a linear
regression
well or something because of the
relationships between the variables so
yes picking picking say
a value for x1 that you kind of want to
use to maximize your ability to like
recover this conditional distribution
doesn't just maximize your ability to
recover that one it also
like can help you recover this
distribution
um so that paper kind of goes through
some of the details of
uh
how you kind of
combine all of the information that you
might be getting
um
and like pick interventions that are
kind of optimal for that rather than
just doing it separately
um i'm not sure this is a good question
to ask but
what uh what you just showed us was that
if you if you place additional
assumptions like fidelity or some
modularity obviously uh very nice things
happen yeah but in a real world scenario
like are these fair like assumptions
yeah so the question is like some
modularity uh
chordality are these fair assumptions to
make in the real world um thing yeah i i
think i see this as a starting point um
and kind of maybe analyzing deviations
from that so how far off of chordality
how part off of uh some modularity of
this function um when you know
how well that impact like what can i
tolerate
maybe i'm mistaken but it didn't seem
like some modularity was an assumption
that you made yeah something that
actually
happened
no so right so neither of these are
assumptions that we make cordelia is
also derived from um
the kind of
details of what interventions allow us
to learn in the graph but
i guess both of those are kind of
predicated on
assumptions kind of further back in the
stack and especially with estimation
error and stuff
we saw for example with the causal
structure discovery lecture that
um
the
kind of conditional independence is
there might actually be kind of
conflicts in those and you have to have
ways of resolving those conflicts so
assumptions that are made in kind of the
population
setting
don't always necessarily translate to
things in the statistical setting like
you might not be confident enough to
direct one of your edges in your
intervention
but you might be confident enough to
direct
some of the other ones and that would
break say like the quartality property
um and i could also see something like
that breaking some modularity
yeah
well before when it's worth just putting
it out
uh there that there has been a lot of
work in this module optimization
you know
community where
you know
this one minus whatever e result was if
you could access your function exactly
exactly here your function is an
expectation
which i could sample from that
distribution yeah
but i probably can't
exactly estimate the
patient
but there is work in the submodular
world like okay my modular function is
the average of many of them i can
perhaps sample this leads to some like
i can't estimate my oracle i don't have
an oracle for the function exactly so
there is
in that i don't know the extent which
has been plugged in here yeah but that
does something that i know of but it
shouldn't so it has andrea's crows as
well
so so the plugging in for example using
like
non-monotonically increasing somewhat of
therapy for these problems but but not
even non-monotonic i guess i'm referring
to like but the same for the expectation
it was also interesting
but yeah i think there's a lot to be
done there i think yeah yeah just one
person is not enough to find the whole
community and we'll be fun yeah yeah
yeah because i'm just saying um andreas
krabs has done some work on this and
has looked at some of the
experimental design for causal structure
learning problems like some of the
results but
there could be more
i just want to understand in typical
gene alcohol experiments are those
interventions more like do interventions
or more like self-intervention
my understanding is that it's
more like soft interventions
um
so you'll you'll down regulate
um i guess in a
true gene knockout you would completely
actually remove
so does that mean it's actually better
than the worst case that uh
that did prove you know
yeah so
uh
is it better than the worst case i think
that um
you might need a few additional
assumptions on the kind of way it
changed the distribution so
it kind of like you know this
faithfulness thing or something like
technically within the class of soft
interventions or
do interventions but if you assume
specifically that you rule those out you
rule out perfect interventions
uh then you at least retain like you
know this dependence information between
interventions which is kind of you know
one of the problems that we have
um so i think you would be able to do
better
if you analyze like specific cases
okay
uh i also don't see any more questions
so we'll take a break till two o'clock
it's always for lunch thank you very
much
you